[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen hier bei Bild ein
historischer flucht-winter kann das
werden so viele Flüchtlinge wie seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr vor allem
aus der Ukraine und wer noch nicht weiß
warum der muss auf diese
Satellitenbilder hier schauen von der
NASA die Ukraine am Tag bevor der Krieg
begann aus der Luft aus dem All gesehen
und jetzt im Dunkeln Putin hat das Licht
ausgebäumt und die Heizung dazu dunkel
und eiskalt jetzt wo in der Ukraine
Dauerfrost herrscht Schneefeld der
größte Flucht Winter seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg und die große Frage was müssen
wir tun und wo sind auch unsere Grenzen
die richtigen Fragen jetzt an oskara von
denen den Ex SPD-Chef x Finanzminister
Marie Agnes strafzimmermann FDP Chefin
des Verteidigungsausschusses im
Bundestag
Zuschauer ist bei uns der
csu-bundestagsabgeordnete früher
wirtschaftsverkehrsminister Michael
Müller der langjährige Regierende
Bürgermeister von Berlin jetzt
außenexperte der Publizist Matthias
Nicolaidis der und sagt wir schaffen das
gerade nicht mehr und Gerald Knaus der
flüchtlingsexperte in Europa erwarnt
jetzt vor einem solchen historischen
fluchtwinter in allen schönen guten
Abend Herr Ramsauer die
bundesinnenministerin die hat jetzt
aktuell bei einem fluchtgipfel auf
europäischer Ebene nicht teilgenommen
weil sie gesagt hat wir haben ja aktuell
gar keine migrationskrise Stimmen sie zu
ihrem schwarzsekretär geschickt ich war
bei den EU-Minister
Gipfeln immer selbst dabei auch wenn ein
Thema nicht wichtig war da hat man da zu
sein als Bundesminister im
Ministerrat der vor allem wichtige
Entscheidungen die man hinterher wenn
sie nicht richtig laufen auszulöffeln
hat Kollege Michael Müller weil sie
regierende ehemaliger Bürgermeister von
Berlin davon ein Lied zu singen denn es
ist nur nicht nur Bundesrecht sondern
auch
landesrechte es gibt im Moment keine
große migrationskrise wie sie das gesagt
hat dann ist die Frau irgendwo vom
anderen sterben sie möchte ja
Ministerpräsidentin in Hessen werden
aber so wird es bestimmt nicht wer Augen
im Kopf hat und jemand wie ich erlebe
der sehr täglich bei meinem
Bürgermeister und 50 Bürgermeister in
meinem Wahlkreis ganz im Süden von
Bayern wenn ich das so sagen darf wie
das klingt der letzte von Bayern wo die
Leute am allerliebsten in Urlaub hin von
Berchtesgaden
da kommt natürlich die Balkanroute an
von Salzburg über die bayerische oder
deutsche Grenze und dann werden jetzt
die Turnhallen der Schulen und so weiter
voll gemacht im Jahr Zweck Räume der
Gemeinden und da kommt richtig Stimmung
auf und wenn die dann hören von der
deutschen Innenministerin da ist findet
nichts statt dann fühlen die Leute sich
natürlich verschaukelt wie kann man als
Ministerin
Frau streckt Zimmermann offenbar wie
Herr Ramsauer das schildert so daneben
liegen
also ich würde da mit ein bisschen
sachlicher umgehen ich weiß jetzt nicht
warum ob das der einzige Grund war das
kann ich jetzt auch nicht beurteilen
nein ich finde Herr Ramsauer sie sind
erfahren und wissen das Ministerinnen
und Ministern möglicherweise war was
anderes ist es geht gar keine Rolle
Aussage migrationskrise ja oder nein das
kann ich gar nicht beurteilen
in der Tat ist es so dass wir momentan
1,2 Millionen ukrainische Flüchtlinge in
Deutschland haben neben Polen und
anderen Nachbarstaaten sind wir das Land
was am meisten aufgenommen hat das liegt
auch an der Nähe natürlich zu Ukraine
wir wissen ja bei Fluchtbewegung gehen
die Menschen sozusagen gar nicht weit
weg in absoluten Zahlen haben wir so
viel aufgenommen
dass Menschen natürlich als sogenannte
Binnenflüchtlinge in der Nähe zumindest
das eigene Landes bleiben in der
Hoffnung dass sie wieder zurückkehren
und in der Tat momentan steigen die
Zahlen nicht angesichtsdrama sie haben
es ja gerade gezeigt dass Putin ähm
jetzt versucht nachdem die militärisch
ein bisschen Erfolg hat den er glaubte
nicht nur die Menschen zu quellen und
umzubringen das ist ja unvorstellbar was
ich da abspielt sondern er möchte
natürlich eins erreichen er möchte dass
durch die Migration der Einhalt der
Europäischen Union der Einheit des
eigenen Staates unterminiert wird also
auf gut deutscher Weg aufeinander
losgehen wegen dieses Thema sagen sauer
hat ja schon mal ein gutes Beispiel
gerade gebracht das sollten wir eben
abwehren und zeigen dass wir auch in
einer solchen Zeit natürlich überlegen
müssen ich komme aus der Kommunalpolitik
wie können wir damit umgehen aber wir
sollten nicht gegeneinander Rennen
sondern wir sollten
uns in Acht nehmen das narratives
Wladimir Putin nicht zu bedienen ja wir
müssen aber offen natürlich über die
flüchtlingskrise die wir offenbar ja
aktuell haben über eine Millionen weit
über eine Million insgesamt rund 1,2
knapp 1,3 Millionen aus der Ukraine die
UNO warnt massiv vor vielen vielen
weiteren Millionen Flüchtlingen wenn die
Lage so dramatisch ist aktuell in der
Ukraine nach der das im Moment aussieht
wenn dann die deutsche Innenministerin
eben sagt wir haben doch im Moment gar
keine große migrationskrise in
Deutschland was sagt das über die ja
Flüchtlingspolitik in Deutschland aus
ihrer Meinung nach
ich finde das sehr bedauerlich denn die
Zahlen sind ja eindeutig
wir müssen überlegen wie wir jetzt die
Situation lösen können und für mich gibt
es nur eine Antwort wir müssen
schnellstmöglich einen Waffenstillstand
erreichen wenn wir den Menschen die in
der Ukraine sterben helfen würden die
die dort verletzt werden und die
Menschen die jetzt frieren das ist der
beste Weg und ich freue mich dass der
oberste Soldat der USA mag Mille der
Generalstabschef jetzt gesagt hat wir
brauchen endlich Verhandlungen und
müssen zu einem Waffenstillstand und
einen Frieden kommen das ist die
richtige Antwort das heißt sie würden
jetzt noch vor dem Winter große
Zugeständnisse an Moskau machen
man muss verhandeln was bei den
Verhandlungen herauskommt wird man dann
sehen aber versuchen muss man es denn
ein Waffenstillstand wäre die beste und
die größte Hilfe für alle Menschen die
jetzt leiden
angesichts dieser humanitären
Katastrophe Frau Zimmermann ganz schnell
zu entlassontainer sagt jetzt bevor wir
weiter diskutieren ganz schnell nach
Moskau fahren und Verhandlungen
aufnehmen
angesichts dieser Katastrophe die sich
da möglicherweise anbahnt der richtige
Weg na ja das ist die Welt des Oscar
Lafontaine dass man offensichtlich einen
guten Draht hatte früher und dann mal in
Moskau an rief
in der Tat es gibt zwei Szenarien die
Russen hören umgehend auf ziehen sich
zurück aus der Ukraine dann ist der
Krieg sofort und umgehen beendet oder
die Ukraine wehrt sich nicht mehr dann
ist die Ukraine von der Bildfläche
verschwunden das sind die Alternativen
momentan und insofern ist es unsere
Aufgabe die Ukraine in ihrer
Wehrhaftigkeit zu unterstützen und uns
eben auch so wie möglich uns Flüchtlinge
natürlich im Kontext Europas zu kümmern
wir sprechen über die flüchtlingslage
Knaus und sie forschen zu diesem Thema
seit vielen Jahren sind vielleicht in
Europa der Migration der
flüchtlingsexperte was droht dort sie
sprechen von dem historischen
fluchtwinter was bedeutet das in Zahlen
naja was wir jetzt schon haben ist die
größte Zahl von Flüchtlingen die seit
den 40er Jahren also seit auch danach
Kriegszeit das sind ja Millionen
Deutsche auch nach Deutschland das
Flüchtlinge gekommen aber seit den 40ern
hatten wir so etwas noch nie erlebt und
das ist jetzt schon die Situation und
wie frau Zimmermann ja auch klar sagt es
ist eine politische Strategie die
fluchtursache ist hat einen Namen das
ist Wladimir Putin sein Ziel ist es
Europäer und das ist vielleicht die
letzte Karte der noch spielt weil die
der Terror hat die Ukraine besetzt nur
entschlossener gemacht weiter zu kämpfen
aber seine Hoffnung ist die Europäer zu
spalten dass die Europäer die Ukraine
fallen lassen und dazu setzt er auf
Zerstörung der Infrastruktur er hat
allerdings muss man dazu sagen schon
fast ein Drittel der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung als ihren Häusern vertrieben
aber die allermeisten und das ist in der
Debatte hier wichtig sind in der Ukraine
geblieben oder sogar zurückgekehrt sogar
viele vergangenen Ende des Winters seit
April es gibt einen Tag 15 April aus dem
ersten Mal mehr Ukraine aus Polen
zurückgehen als kommen wir haben
eigentlich die letzten Monate eine
Rückkehr gehabt weil das sind Frauen es
in Kinder vor allem die zurück wollen zu
ihren Vätern jede Männern fällt die
Elektrizität immer wieder aufs Neue aus
die Heizung fällt aus und wir sprechen
jetzt über Eiskalte Temperaturen jetzt
mit Blick auf die nächsten anderthalb
Wochen Dauerfrost in der Ukraine das ist
eine eine Katastrophe es ist auch ein
permanentes Kriegsverbrechen das auch
zeigt wie Ernstes Wladimir Putin meint
auch wieder die Stadt casson wie die
übergeben wurde alles zerstört da kann
man im Winter nicht leben und daher
müssen wir uns jetzt darauf einstellen
wenn wir diese Erpressung nicht
standhalten wollen aber den Konsens in
der Gesellschaft bewahren wollen dass
wir in Deutschland in Europa in den
Ländern und das sind zum Glück die
meisten nicht alle aber die meisten die
bereit sind Leute aufzunehmen dass wir
uns so organisieren dass das über diesen
Winter hinaus bis zum April funktioniert
darüber sprechen wir gleich und Details
Herr Müller haben sie für Berlin Beginn
im Moment ein Überblick wie viele
Menschen aus der Ukraine wie viele
Flüchtlinge man da insgesamt in den
vergangenen Monaten mittlerweile
aufgenommen hat und gut 90.000 das ist
ungefähr auch vergleichbar mit denen die
2015/2016 gekommen sind das war auch
innerhalb von acht Wochen sind ungefähr
100.000 sind zusätzlich in die Stadt
gekommen das natürlich eine
Riesenaufgabe man will den Menschen ja
auch gut helfen das heißt es geht darum
gute Unterkünfte zu schaffen in einer
Stadt die ohnehin schon eng ist und dann
einen riesen Bevölkerungswachstum hat
und neben der viele schon nicht
funktioniert im Alter ja aber wir haben
ja auch 100.000 Syrien und Syrien helfen
können wir helfen jetzt 90.000 Menschen
aber es geht ja auch nicht nur um
Wohnraum es geht um ärztliche Versorgung
und Beschulung für die Kinder es geht um
Kleidung um Nahrungsmittel es geht um
eine Perspektive wie leicht auch über
den April hinaus es geht um
Integrationsarbeit und das ist natürlich
nicht nur für Berlin für die Städte
Bürgermeisterin hat gesagt sie befindet
sich die Hauptstadt jetzt im Grunde an
der Kapazitätsgrenze das heißt wenn wir
jetzt sprechen über eine neue
Flüchtlingsbewegung möglicherweise
massiv sie können nicht mehr in Berlin
ich frage immer wie ist der
Umkehrschluss deswegen zucke ich auch
bei dem Begriff für migrationskrise oder
flüchtlingskrise
oder
wortkapazitäten müssen wollen wir die
Menschen alleine lassen sie kommen aus
bitterer not sie können in Ihrem Land
was ja die beste Lösung wäre können sie
nicht bleiben wegen der Zustände die wir
gehört haben das heißt sie machen sich
aus guten Grund auf um sich und ihre
Familie zu schützen und wir wollen der
Ukraine helfen militärisch diplomatisch
wie auch immer aber es ist doch auch
unsere humanitäre Pflicht den Menschen
auf der Flucht zu helfen und insofern
auch wenn es für uns eine Belastung ist
und es ist eine Belastung kann man nicht
weg diskutieren es ist auch unsere
Aufgabe weiter zu helfen wenn Sie das
Hören gleichzeitig dieses Dilemma spüren
bei Herrn Müller Herr Ramsauer hat das
bei sich aus Berchtesgaden geschildert
einerseits der Wille zu helfen auf der
anderen Seite ganz klar zu sagen die
Kapazitätsgrenze ist erreicht wie würden
sie es auflösen
ja Gott sei Dank ist nicht meine Aufgabe
ist aufzulösen ich kann es beschreiben
es ist es ist an der Grenze und so sehen
sich die Gemeinden und Landkreise dass
es man mit den Ukrainern eigentlich bis
oben auf voll ist und jetzt kommt eben
noch die Zuwanderung weil die
Balkanroute über im Grunde alle
deutschen Grenzen hinzu wo wir eine
illegale Migration haben die im Asyl
Antrag endet und das ist inzwischen auch
im Steigen begriffen und wir gehen auch
da auf Werte von 2015 16
Ramsauer sagt wir sind jetzt dabei die
Turnhallen wieder zu öffnen das ist was
was glaube ich im Bevölkerung erst recht
nach der coronazeit niemand möchte und
nach den Erfahrungen von 25 16
Berlin die Hauptstadt die
Bürgermeisterin sagt wir sind an der
Kapazitätsgrenze also was jetzt tun in
Berlin werden Zelte gebaut auf dem
Flughafen Tegel und es wird gesagt das
sind das ist aber nicht Moria
also dass man man setzt sich moralisch
ab und macht sich besser und
gleichzeitig macht man im Grunde genau
das gleiche was
sie sprechen gerade
nicht gewesen sein
in diesem Lager gab es einen
Zusammenbruch der Staatlichkeit und
Kontrolle da gab es Vergewaltigungen wo
sich die Polizei nicht hineingetraut hat
das sind auf engster also da ist Berlin
da ist Deutschland so weit davon
entfernt aber wir bauen
machen wieder auf das ist der Winter
helfen wir haben Wohnung zur Verfügung
gestellt die Bundesebene landeseigene
Liegenschaften wir haben Container
gebaut wir nehmen andere Unterkünfte
große eben weil sie Institutionen die
ihre Räumlichkeiten nicht brauchen aber
wir sind jetzt an einer an einem Punkt
wo wir auch mit Zelten so schlimm ist
helfen wollen und helfen müssen weil
sonst haben die Menschen gar keine
Situation wo sie irgendwie diesen Winter
überstehen kann man das muss man das uns
allen in Deutschland im Moment erklären
auch zumuten in dieser tiefen Wirtschaft
in dieser Energiekrise ist das wie Frau
Strack Zimmermann und Herr Müller ja
gesagt haben einfach unsere moralische
Pflicht oder ist dafür sie die Grenze da
muss man einen Unterschied machen ich
meine wenn man die Ukraine Flüchtlinge
nimmt dann ist das natürlich echt und
reale kriegsflucht denn da ist Krieg und
wir sind die direkt Nachbarn als EU und
als schenkenraum das kann man so sehen
und dann haben wir dort eigentlich keine
große Alternative und müssen sagen mehr
oder weniger aufnehmen es ist die Frage
zu welchem Bedingungen nicht wahr wir
haben es wurde hier von der
bundesinnenministerin sofort einen ein
Asylstatus ein Ukraine Flüchtlingen
verliehen ohne Not aus meiner Sicht und
genau und damit sind sie sofort fähig
das im ersten Januar das Bürgergeld zu
beziehen und das ist natürlich auch eine
Art von pulverfaktor da muss man auch
sagen für Ukraine jetzt inzwischen weil
sie Geld haben wollen und zu Hause ist
alles so toll und das ist alles voller
Ernst gesagt das ist
würde ich nicht sagen also gerade jetzt
unterstellt die kommen pull Faktor heißt
ja sie kommen das Geldes wegen das heißt
aber wollen sie bestreiten das ist voll
Faktoren gibt das wäre ja nun ganz ganz
naiv aus politischer Sicht und den
Kindern
in Frankreich
nicht die Geldleistungen und die in
Frankreich sind im Vergleich zu
Deutschland ein Bruchteil von
ukrainischen flüchten ist natürlich auch
sagen können ist doch klar also ich
würde gerne was dazu sagen machen
auf helfen Sie uns einmal und unseren
Zuschauern also wir haben das für
Deutschland äh ja alle parat Hartz 4 bzw
künftiger ab 1 Januar dann das neue
Bürgergeld wie ist die Regelung in
Frankreich also was zahlt Frankreich den
die das Land aufnehmen möchte oder
aufnehmen müsste aus der Ukraine wie
kann ich das noch ein Wort sagen
ist extrem wichtig zur Verteilung in
Europa denn alle europäischen
Innenminister haben beschlossen dass die
Ukraine legal kommen können und sich
überall niederlassen und überall das
Recht haben zu arbeiten zu leben und die
Verteilung hat sich dann ergeben spontan
es gab ein lesefair und das stößt jetzt
an seine Grenze
den Menschen selber überlassen
die meisten Ukraine und das haben sie
selbst gesagt sie natürlich bei den
Nachbarn aber das ist jetzt in
Deutschland
pro Kopf sind die höchsten Zahlen in
molder in Tschechien Tschechien hat
460.000 Anträge 11 Millionen Einwohner
hat alleine mehr Flüchtlinge aufgenommen
als es Bayern getan hat man kann die
Geschichte aber auch umgekehrt sehen
viel mehr aufgenommen hat Frankreich
aufgenommen und da kommen wir auf die
glaube ich wenn wir Lösungen suchen denn
es ist ja es gibt keinen Innenminister
in Europa auch nicht die Ungarn
niemanden der sagt wir wir stoßen die
Ukraine zurück da gibt's die werden
kommen wenn sie fliehen müssen Sie
versuchen zu bleiben das ist ja das
wichtige wenn sie aber kommen dann wird
es entscheidend sein dass wir es
schaffen eine Ungleichgewicht das
Frankreich Spanien Italien zusammen
weniger Ukraine aufgenommen haben als
das Tschechien mit 11 Millionen
Einwohnern ist die Frage wie kriegt man
das ausgeglichen aber ich will doch
dafür von meiner Seite zurück weil bei
den Sozialleistungen war der Vorwurf kam
mir auch von Herrn Nicolaidis die
Sozialleistung sein hier im Vergleich zu
hoch also deswegen ganz schnell einmal
die Fakten klar machen wie ist es in
Frankreich also in Frankreich ist es
tatsächlich so wer als ukrainische Frau
und Kind bekommen einige hundert Euro
Sozialhilfe aber für das Wohnen kommt
man auf 200 Euro und jetzt weiß ich aber
ich habe in Frankreich jahrelang gelebt
in Paris aber überall in Frankreich wenn
man einen Mietvertrag schließen will
damit kann man nicht mieten wenn man
viele Frankreich als Ausländer mieten
müssen ein Jahr Kaution hinterlegen also
es ist unglaublich kompliziert mit dem
Geld kommt man nicht durch was wir aber
merken und das ist das entscheiden ist
ja überall in Europa wir haben das die
Polen geschafft viel mehr aufzunehmen
pro Kopf aus Deutschland weil die
Bevölkerung aufnimmt es nirgendwo auch
in Warschau gibt es nicht so viel
organisierte Quartiere kein
Bürgermeister hat 10.000 oder
hunderttausende freie Wohnungen die
einzige Chance dass in diesem Winter zu
schaffen und jetzt muss der Staat aber
auch etwas tun und ich ich weiß dass das
jetzt im Innenministerium angedacht wird
ich hoffe da kommen schnell
Entscheidungen dass man die privaten die
aufnehmen und das ist die Stütze hier
dass man die auch finanziell mit einer
dankespauschale wie das in England
funktioniert jeden Monat wir könnten 500
€. das kommt den Bund sogar billiger als
das komplizierte System also weg mit
Harz nicht mehr pauschal in das
harzsystem für ukrainische Flüchtlinge
sondern an diejenigen zahlen die
Familien aufnehmen ukrainische Frauen
und Kinder aufnehmen bei sich pauschal
weiß ich 400 € Zimmer man ganz schnell
der Praxis checkt würden sie das machen
finden Sie dass Sie sinnvoll Idee bin
jetzt keine innenpolitikerin also kann
man denen denjenigen die Wohnraum zur
Verfügung stellen einen Obligo gibt es
oder in eine Unterstützung das ist auf
alle Fälle richtig denn es ist in der
Tat so dass der Raum begrenzt ist wir
sprachen ja gerade darüber das Gemeinden
jetzt auch wieder die Turnhallen öffnen
das was wir aus 20 15 kennen und
insofern ist das eine Möglichkeit aber
ja nicht zusätzlich sagt der Klaus
sondern stattdessen
wenn er eine Familie Unterkunft hat und
für die Mutter mit Kind ist es ja viel
weniger kompliziert wenn Sie die meisten
wollen ja nur 4 Monate bleiben über den
Winter die wissen ja die wollen ja jetzt
nicht ein Jahr hier zu wohnen und wenn
sie dann die Chance haben von einer
deutschen Familie oder von deutschen
aufgenommen zu werden auch helfen können
das funktioniert schon Berchtesgaden
möglicherweise erstmal
gleichzeitig Anreize schaffen
meine Wahlkreis Bürger im Chiemgau und
im Berchtesgadener Land ja im Frühjahr
zu aufgetragen jede Menge großartig was
dafür eine Aufnahmebereitschaft aber
aber die hat nachgelassen jetzt habe ich
auch aber nicht nur bei einem Organes
sondern ganz allgemein weil eben
Beobachtungen gemacht werden die die
Geduld der Leute der Bevölkerung in
Deutschland schon sehr strapaziert also
zum Beispiel das wollte ich sie ja
gerade fragen als als
migrationswissenschaftler ich habe mir
heute mal angeschaut die Reisetätigkeit
zwischen Deutschland und der Ukraine
was da an hin und her permanenter
Reiserei ist
ein Beispiel dieser Woche wenn Sie
klicken jetzt kommenden Freitag 2
Dezember fahren allein aus Berlin 32
flixbusse
zu Destination nach Kiew nur nach Kiew
davon sind 24 bereits ausgebucht und
endlich die Situation zurück aus zehn
Großstädten in Deutschland insgesamt ein
ähnliches Bild hinterlegt das wollte ich
denn wissen
ich glaube da muss man nur mit ein paar
dieser Ukrainerinnen reden die sind
getrennt von ihren Männern von ihren
Vätern von ihren Söhnen wenn Sie
volljährig sind dürfen sie nicht
ausreisen das ist ein Krieg die die
Männer dürfen nicht raus zwischen 18 und
64 aber da kann man als praktisch
zurückfahren
können
Sie leicht beantworten das ist ja nicht
eine Situation wie in Syrien wo man sich
vor der Regierung fürchten muss man die
fürchten sich ja nicht für ihre
Regierung die fürchten sich vor dem
Drohnen den Bomben den Granaten und
natürlich im Grunde genommen müssten wir
froh darüber sein dass sehr sehr viele
in den ersten Wochen die größte
Flüchtling Millionen in wenigen Wochen
die gekommen sind sehr sehr viele sobald
es ging sobald es wärmer würde
zurückgefahren sind und zu sehen können
wir wieder in unserer Wohnung sein und
sehr viele sind zurückgekehrt Millionen
aber der Vorwurf ist ja ganz klar von
den Ramsauer
ganz klare Frage
von Wirtschaftswissenschaften zu
Migration ich wollte das einmal machen
ich wollte das einmal ganz klar
aussprechen weil das Ziel ja in die
Diskussion die Herr März auch angetextet
hat im übrigen in dieser Sendung als er
das Wort sozial Tourismus genutzt hat
was er anschließend was er anschließen
dann mit der Entschuldigung
zurückgenommen hat frau Zimmermann also
Herr Ramsauer liegt die Reise Tätigkeit
über die Bevölkerung in seinem Wahlkreis
und sagt da gibt's nämlich Stimmung und
man fragt sich warum diese Reise
Tätigkeit vorherrscht und der verknüpft
das mit der Diskussion um Sozialleistung
was ist denn ihre Antwort darauf also
können wir den Vorwurf können wir den
Vorwurf entkräften ich hätte gerne
heransauer Sprache sei so eine
Missstimmung zwischen und dann hat er
leider abgebrochen ich hätte es gern mal
konkret an dem Beispiel gehabt was sie
meinen um darauf zu sagen als Beispiel
gebracht
ich werde dann gefragt
wir sollen aufnehmen aber warum wird da
diese starke Reise Tätigkeit
getätigt warum werden die hohen
Sozialleistungen gewährt noch Hartz IV
warum kommentiert dann ins Bürgergeld
hinein
also
Antwort ja das sage ich dann immer das
sind berechtigte Fragen bitte beachten
Sie wir sind in der Opposition wir haben
das nicht zu bestimmen doch das ist
Argumentation ja ja ja ja ja ja ja und
jetzt wieder in der Opposition wir
können das alleine nicht stören dann
sagen die Leute ja aber wir werden doch
irgendwas immer noch Einfluss haben und
sagt mir selbstverständlich wir tun
unsere Möglichkeit zum
Beispiel den Kompromiss beim Bürgergeld
jetzt herbeizuführen mit den Elementen
die sie ja alle kennen gesprochen
im Moment mit den Zahlen an mittlerweile
rund 1,2 knapp 1,3 Millionen ukrainische
Flüchtlinge also was wäre ihre Lösung
die Leistung wegnehmen zu sagen wir
haben eine Obergrenze plötzlich also was
sagen sie den Menschen im Berchtesgaden
gemacht gerade gemacht hat die Ursache
allen Übels muss man natürlich angehen
und ich gehöre auch zu denen die sagen
muss im Verhandlungen eintreten wie auch
immer das mache gegen meine eigenen
Parteilinie sein und gegen manchen
Draufgänger auch in meiner Fraktion der
am liebsten auch noch kampfschutz
liefern möchte da bin ich direkt dagegen
ich bin auch direkt dagegen dass Waffen
mit offensiv Charakter geliefert werden
die auf Russisch ist auf echtes
russisches Gebiet schießen können
Bindestrich nichts dagegen und eine das
selenski hat das letzte Woche gefordert
letzte lensky hat es gefordert Gefahren
keinerlei Zusagen aber ich meine wenn
die Diskussion liebe Frau Zimmermann
aufkommen ich wäre nein ich bin gar
nichts durcheinander ich sage ja nur
nein die Richtung Russland
abgefahrenski ich habe doch gerade
erklärt selensky hat das gefordert und
wenn der sowas fordert dann kommt der
schnell bei uns so eine Diskussion im
Gang wie weit kann man gehen ich wollte
ja nur sagen ich wollte nur ich wollte
ja sagen ich gehöre nicht zu denen die
Richtung Draufgängertum gehen sondern zu
denjenigen die sagen jetzt muss
irgendwann mal fahren
schon gesagt
ein bisschen
und auf Seiten hier von Lafontaine zu
reden miteinander und am Ende zu sehen
was kommt dabei raus und dann beginnt
Verhandlungen entsteht immer ein
Waffenstillstand
setzen wieder von Heizungen von Energie-
gleichzeitig auch aus kalafontaine das
hatten wir in der Geschichte auch noch
nicht so oft CSU in diesem Fall
zumindest Peter Ramsau und Oskar
Lafontaine auf einer Linie
gegebenen Folgen auch dieser
Fluchtbewegung gesprochen der Lafontaine
spüren wir die bereits sozialen Folgen
dieser flüchtlingskrise dieses nahenden
möglicherweise historischen
fluchtwetters
ich möchte doch die wichtigste Frage
ansprechen die wichtigste Frage ist
dafür wie diese Fluchtbewegung dämpfen
können vielleicht sogar ganz bewältigen
können darüber müssen wir doch Gedanken
machen deshalb freue ich mich dass Herr
Ramsauer sagt wir müssen eben versuchen
zu einem verwaffenstillstand zu kommen
und zu Verhandlungen zu kommen und ich
wundere mich mit welcher ja ich sag mal
Handbewegung Frau stark Zimmermann das
wegwischen will ich habe extra noch den
US-General eingeführt die dies fordert
mit ihrer Politik Frau stark Zimmermann
Waffen liefern Waffenlieferung werden
also die Probleme immer weiter zunehmen
die Fluchtbewegung wird zunehmen die
Menschen werden frieren es werden
Menschen sterben wir brauchen jetzt ein
Waffenstillstand wir brauchen
Verhandlungen wir brauchen ich sag's
ihnen mal historisch mehr Genscher als
drei Zimmer Mannschaft in seinem letzten
Interview noch geworben für
Verständigung mit Russland was ich von
ihnen höre ist für mich einfach nicht
nachvollziehbar und das verstehe ich
deswegen sind sie bei den Linken und den
Freien Demokraten aber was ist ihre
Antwort daraufhin sagt gerade sie wissen
dass du weg mit einem Handschellen
ich halte die Situation für sehr sehr
ernst und ich wiederhole mich ungern
aber für Herrn Lafontaine mache ich es
gerne noch mal es gibt zwei Ebenen das
eine den Russen nahezulegen umgehend mit
diesem mörderischen Überfall aufzuhören
die die die Soldaten zurückzuziehen
aufzuhören das Land zu bombardieren dann
ist der Krieg umgehen und sofort zu Ende
so und die Alternative ist dass es
weitergeht und die Ukraine sagt wir
machen nichts mehr und dann ist die
Ukraine morgen Geschichte
sie tun im Moment nicht alles um diesen
Krieg tatsächlich ja dahin bringen zu
können dass er zu einem Ende bringt zu
Ende bringt das heißt sie tun auch nicht
alles um zu verhindern dass es zu einer
massiven weiteren Fluchtbewegung in
diesem Winter kommt das muss man ja
separieren es geht darum
Putin eben nur die Sprache der Stärke
versteht das zeigt sich ja auch dass sie
eben
also so weit geht es dann doch nicht das
Putin nur die diese Sprache versteht mit
dem mit dem Erfolg dass er eben weil er
militärisch keinen Erfolg hat er hat ja
geglaubt in 14 Tagen sah das alles
erledigt jetzt ist das schon der zehnte
Monat eben andere Methoden einsetzt es
ist das Thema Fluchtbewegung ist das
Thema Ernährungskrise ist das Thema
Energie das heißt er nutzt alles um uns
jetzt sozusagen aufeinander loszulassen
weil er ja davon ausgeht die Europäer
sind alles Weicheier und die werden
verstehen sie heller von denen die
Sprache von den Putin nicht
ich glaube dass ich über die Erfahrung
verfüge was in den letzten Jahrzehnten
war wir hatten die Politik der
Entspannung und der Verständigung an der
auch die FDP hervorragend mitgewirkt hat
deswegen wundere ich mich ja so über die
für mich völlig nach nicht
nachvollziehbare Position von Frau
Strack Zimmermann die FDP hat auf die
Entspannung gesetzt wir hatten Frieden
in Europa dann kam die Politik in der
Spannung des Aufrüstens dann kam der
Jugoslawienkrieg jetzt kommt der Ukraine
Krieg also wenn man immer nur Waffen
ruft dann wird man das Morden und die
Flucht wird man verlängern das muss ich
in aller Härte Frau stark Zimmermann
vorwerfen wir brauchen wie Genscher es
gesagt hat Verständigung mit Russland
ohne Verständigung mit Russland gibt es
keinen Frieden das ist eine harter
Vorschlag Zimmermann sie verlängern dass
morgen ist alles gut das trage ich mit
breiten Schultern vor allen Dingen wenn
jemand wie er da Fontänen der länger auf
dieser Erde ist als ich und eigentlich
die Geschichte besser kennen sollte
nämlich dahingehend dass es in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik nach 1945
es ist ja sehr beliebt von den Linken
die die den NATO-Einsatz um den Kosovo
zu unterstützen dass die Menschen dort
nicht gezielt umgebracht werden das
jetzt das verglichen wird es gab in der
Geschichte der UN die er nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg gegründet worden ist
kein vergleichbaren Situation wie jetzt
Russland wladimir Putin hat
völkerrechtswidrig die Ukraine
überfallen und will sie und das bildet
sich Frau Zimmermann nicht ein von der
Landkarte verschwinden lassen und zwar
wir reden hier nicht nur in
Anführungszeichen von der Ostukraine ist
schon eine große Fläche sondern von dem
ganzen Land und der fing an 20 14 mit
der Annektion der Krim also und wir sind
völkerrechtskonform helfen der Ukraine
sich zu Wert zu setzen das ist eine
Realität und um noch mal auf die
Flüchtlinge zurückzukommen ja es ist in
der Tat für die Städte und Gemeinden
eine riesen Herausforderung wenn ich
jetzt in meine Stadt Düsseldorf schaue
wir haben 2015 eine große Infrastruktur
aufgebaut weil zur beobachten war das
Flüchtlinge lieber in Großstädte gehen
wo sie sozusagen ihre Kollegen vor allen
Dingen eben nach Berlin nach Dresden
nach Leipzig Richtung
so dass sie dort hingehen wo
möglicherweise schon Freunde Verwandte
sind das würden wir ja nicht anders
machen und insofern sind die Städte der
unterschiedlich aufgestellt wir hatten
das seinerzeit sozusagen direkt dem Büro
des Oberbürgermeisters unterstellt es
gab eine flüchtlingsbeauftragte die das
koordiniert hat auf dieser Ebene hat die
Stadt jetzt wieder sozusagen angesetzt
aus Erfahrung trotzdem sind die Zahlen
natürlich groß und deswegen noch mal die
Frage wie weit man privat Menschen
unterbringen hat teile ich dass man dort
ansetzt um ihn auch etwas zu geben um
die Situation zu vereinfachen es ist
natürlich so es geht jetzt wir haben
jetzt bald Dezember das sind jetzt vier
Monate und die Frage bei aller
Problematik und da brauchen die Kommunen
ich war selber Bürgermeisterin der Stadt
Düsseldorf auch entsprechende
Unterstützung aber die Frage wird sein
sind wir in der Lage auch emotional vier
Monate diesen Menschen zu helfen und ich
wirklich bei aller Diskussionen Streit
ich erwarte von jedem von uns ein Hauch
nur ein Funken Empathie für das was in
der Ukraine gerade passiert ich war
zweimal da und ich möchte wirklich Gott
befohlen dass nie erleben müssen als
Großmutter und Mutter von Kindern das zu
erleben Empathie müssen wir ja es gehört
auch endlich Gefühl und natürlich auch
Finanzen wir haben nur wir haben vor
zwei Wochen genau diesen Streit auch
über die sozialen Folgen über die
sozialen Kosten auch geführt und ganz
einfach die Zahlen einmal auf den Tisch
liegt aber ihr Kollege Ralf steht noch
bei uns in der Sendung und wir haben
einfach nur einmal ihn gefragt ob bei
den aktuell weiß wie viele Ukrainer im
Moment Hartz-IV-Leistungen beziehen wie
viel Flüchtlinge insgesamt wie viel
Ausländer hartz-
wie groß ist der Anteil an Ausländern
bei Hartz IV wissen sie das
ne ich weiß das nicht aber ich vermute
schon dass es ein erheblichen Anteil
gibt und das ist jedenfalls da eine
Menge mehr tun können um
20% keine Ahnung
vielleicht 20%, das sind 20 für
mittlerweile finde ich es sind
tatsächlich mittlerweile 45 Prozent mein
Thema jetzt mal das ist mein Thema weil
sie sagen zu war noch nicht
Sozialsysteme entschuldigung das ist
wirklich jemand die Sozialsysteme zu
Nikola Idee ist dann wurde sehr
emotional in dieser Sendung obwohl wir
eigentlich nur über die Zahlen
gestritten haben dass deutet darauf hin
dass es tabuisiert wird in Deutschland
ja und ich finde auch wir sind auch so
ein bisschen auf eine schiefe Ebene
geraten gerade mit ihrem Vortrag vor
stark Zimmermann wo ist nur darum geht
diese Sache jetzt sozusagen zu
verarbeiten in Deutschland alles
unterzubringen was an jeden
unterzubringen der ankommt und
un- und es zu schaffen auf deutsch
gesagt ich war aber das ist nicht allein
die Aufgabe sie hatten schon als
Regierung die Aufgabe meine ich auch
sich um die illegal im Generation etwas
mehr zu kümmern weil das nämlich oben
drauf kommt wir können gerne sagen
Ukraine Flucht und da haben sie mich ein
bisschen unterbrochen das ist durchaus
legitim ja es gibt auch dort Anreize
aber ist die Anreise wirken viel stärker
natürlich auf die illegale Migration die
seit sieben Jahren jetzt noch nach
Deutschland kommt
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen gesprochen und
sie haben dann die Frage der
Sozialsysteme Einwanderung also diesen
pull-effekt
genau ich war gar nicht fertig das hatte
aber auch schon gesagt dass wir das
bitte nein das haben sie überhört
aber das ist jetzt sehr sehr
besonders vor allen Dingen wenn man von
dem eigentlichen Thema ablenkt sondern
sie haben gerade gesagt Ukraine
pulleffekt und da habe ich gesagt an
diesem Punkt
definitiv sage und keinem ukrainischen
Flüchtling der gerade vor Bomben und
Terror flieht deswegen zu kommen um in
der Sozialsystem zu ziehen sich der
anderen Diskussionen der Welt geht auch
das muss man noch mal ganz klar sie
sprechen über Einwanderung in die
Sozialsysteme sie nehmen die Ukraine
dort ausdrücklich aus und sprechen über
diejenigen die auf der Balkanroute sind
der Knaus wie groß sind die Zahlen der
aktuell wenn wir ich ich mache es ganz
konkrete Beispiel Baden-Württemberg da
kann ich die Zahl nicht vor kurzem
wieder angesehen von den von 11
Flüchtlingen die mir aufgenommen in
diesem Jahr aufgenommen wurden
was die Asylanträge betrifft sind wir
überhaupt nicht vergleichbar mit 2015
damals kamen in 12 Monaten
2017 aus 2014 da hatten wir diese Zahlen
ihre Heimatland schlägt aktuell Alarm
auch wegen der Zahlen von der
Balkanroute und Österreich Herr Ramsauer
hat das schon geschildert winkt im
Moment weitestgehend durch nach
Deutschland auf die 200.000 kommen Herr
Knaus das wissen auch sie also noch
einmal wir haben im Jahr 2015 in 12
Monaten eine Million Menschen gehabt die
aus der Türkei über das Meer nach
Griechenland kamen wir haben in diesem
Jahr bekannt 12.000 das ist was wir
derzeit erleben ist keine große neue
irreguläre Migration in die Europäische
Union weil wir haben machen
ist das in Griechenland Menschen so
behandelt werden dass sogar anerkannte
Flüchtlinge und zwar 40.000 anerkannte
Flüchtlinge vertrieben werden weil sie
dort nicht leben können nach Deutschland
kommen einen Antrag stellen und die
deutschen verwaltungsgerichtete
der deutschen verwaltungsgerichtet
übrigens ganz viele europäischen Ländern
es gibt keine Rückführung nach
Griechenland
Teil die Menschenwürde der Menschen dort
aufgrund der Verletzungen der
europäischen Standards in Griechenland
ich garantiert sind das bedeutet dass
eine kleine Zahl von Ländern Österreich
zählt dazu Griechen ja Österreich die
Schweiz 22.000 Asylanträge pro Kopf
dieses Jahr mehr ist also er Klaus sagt
die Zahlen sind klein das sind
diejenigen die bisher in der
Griechenland untergebracht sind das ist
kein Migration aus Griechenland
die großen migrationstürmer einfach
schweigen
da wachsen die Flüchtlinge nicht auf den
Bäumen die müssen in den Westen
ist gekommen
Entschuldigung wo wir gerade sprechen
die kommen aus der Türkei nach
Griechenland nach Bulgarien und gehen
dann auf den balkanal
sind so immer
zu Hause gar nicht wir sprechen
Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme das
kommt nämlich aktuell von ihrem
Fraktionschef von Friedrich Merz wen
meint er damit
natürlich nicht nur ukrainische
Flüchtlinge die sich angezogen fühlen
natürlich durch das was sie vorhin
gesagt haben
aber trotzdem noch Zimmermann das allein
ist natürlich kein Fluchtgrund will das
noch mal klarstellen
weil sie mich vorhin so interpretiert
haben aber wir haben auf der Balkanroute
natürlich große Stauräume anders wäre es
nicht zu erklären dass Österreich haben
ich bin ja mit meinem Wahlkreis halber
Österreicher und da geht alles so
ineinander ich habe alleine in meinem
Wahlkreis ungefähr 20 Grenzübergänge die
kann man überhaupt nicht kontrollieren
was glauben Sie was da reinkommt also
die sind nicht alle mit Autos befahrbar
sondern bequem mit
Fahrrad und zu Fuß und mit Rucksack und
also das da geht viel rüber klar also
jeder der nach Deutschland möchte
bei meinem Punkt
aber jeder der nach Deutschland möchte
kommt nach Deutschland es wird immer
irgendwer schreibt aber natürlich die
Innenministerin hat auch mit der
Bundespolizei die Grenzkontrollen jetzt
verstärkt in Absprache mit Österreich
mit Tschechien da wird auch einiges
getane Wege geben nur
alle nach Deutschland kommen
Diskussion weil was machen wir uns
eigentlich vor was noch auf uns zukommt
wenn man sich mal die Situation auf der
Welt anguckt wir reden hier über die
Ukraine wir reden über den Balkan was
eigentlich im Nahen Osten kostenlos
im Irak im Syrien zwischen 50 und 70
Grad weitere Regionen dieses Landes in
diesem Sommer das heißt sie sind
unbewohnbare Länder das heißt die Rechte
werden viel viel viel größer so wie so
wie Norwegen Italien Schweden wird sich
Deutschland in den nächsten Jahren damit
auseinandersetzen müssen dass wir ganz
andere Migrationsfragen haben in anderen
Größenordnung das ist ein und die Frage
des Einwanderungslandes zu welchem
Politiker Dimension gehen
dass wir jetzt in dieser Situation
Menschen die vor unserer Haustür Leben
aufnehmen auch wenn es für uns hart ist
finde ich nach wie vor eine
Selbstverständlichkeit
in Frankreich sind oder haben wir
diskutiert
und sie werden auch weiter hier
herkommen weil sie in nächster Nähe zu
ihrer Heimat ist ein sicheren Ort suchen
um aber weiter Kontakt zu halten zu
ihrer Heimat und das ist keine
Reisetätigkeit im Sinne von Urlaub wenn
Sie mit dem flixbus zurückfahren sondern
sie gucken ob Ihr Haus noch steht ob ihr
Vater noch lebt und das ist normal
Selbstverständlichkeit dafür die
Politiker Michael Müller der gerade auch
die Innenministerin genannt hat und die
hat aktuell in Mitten dieser Krise vor
die Einbürgerung deutlich zu
beschleunigen darüber streiten wir
gleich hier weiter bei Bild noch eine
andere Frage zurück bei Bild die
richtigen Fragen in diesem Jahr
möglicherweise historischen Flucht
Winter so wie es die experten nennen und
inmitten dessen kommt der politische
Vorschlag aus der Bundesregierung die
Einbürgerung deutlich zu beschleunigen
die Innenministerin Nancy fazer will
genau das den deutschen Pass erleichtern
Herr Müller warum
wir müssen uns mal ehrlich machen ganz
jenseits von Syrien oder Ukraine wir
sind eigentlich seit Jahrzehnten ein
Einwanderungsland und wir brauchen
Einwanderung gerade auch wegen der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung damit
dieses Land sich positiv
weiterentwickeln kann brauchen wir
Einwanderung und Einwanderung muss auch
Regeln kennen
Staatsbürgerschaft muss Regeln kennen
und deswegen ist jetzt etwas zu
verabreden wann kann und sollte wer auch
deutscher Staatsbürger werden können
nach welcher Aufenthaltsdauer hier mit
welchen Sprachkenntnissen kann er sein
Leben alleine beschützen
weniger Sprachkenntnisse auch die die
Bedingungen sind weiterhin da deutsche
Sprache sein Leben bestreiten können
dauerhafter Wohnsitz hier alles das ist
weiterhin Bedingungen aber erleichtert
damit wir auch Zuwanderung stärker
geregelte Zuwanderung mit
Staatsbürgerschaft ermöglichen Hella von
denen ist das ihre Auffassung nach eine
soziale eine gute
gute Idee auch zur Integration so wie es
die Innenministerin ja sagt
ich stimme zu wir brauchen Einwanderung
das geben die Zahlen her
aber man muss natürlich auch sagen dass
Einwanderung immer begrenzt sein muss
das ist ja schon eine Aussage die viele
Politikerinnen und Politiker sich nicht
mehr trauen und die Einwanderung das
sieht man jetzt an der Diskussion wird
umso schwerer wenn wir in einer solchen
Situation sind wie jetzt das eben viele
Flüchtlinge kommen und dann ist sinkt
die Aufnahmen Bereitschaft der
Bevölkerung wer etwas anderes sagt hat
die letzten Jahre nicht miterlebt
insofern Einwanderung ja aber immer
begrenzt und eben der jeweiligen
Situation angepasst und wenn es also
schon um Einwanderung in das
Arbeitsleben geht möchte ich einen
Gedanken hinzufügen Einwanderung darf
nicht
missbraucht werden zum Lohndumping das
ist eine wichtige zusatzbemerkung die
man machen muss jetzt haben wir aber
über Einwanderung und über ein bürgerung
gesprochen Frau streckt Zimmermann sie
haben gerade
von denen gesprochen hat beim Thema dass
die Aufnahmebereitschaft dann sinkt in
Deutschland das hat sie offenbar gestört
aber die Frage ganz konkret zu der
Einbürgerung also die FDP steht ja
offenbar gerade auf der Bremse in der
Koalition sie auch werden Sie mir
Gelegenheit geben sortiere ich das
gerade bitte anders so wir haben jetzt
diskutiert über das Thema Flucht und
Vertreibung ja das hat damit gar nichts
zu tun so das zweite also mit der Frage
Einwanderung wir haben in der
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart dass wir
das was unter der cdu/csu Jahrzehnte
lang verhindert wurde weil diese Partei
eben nicht erkannter das wäre ein
Einwanderungsland sind das sind andere
Länder durchaus weiter gesagt wir müssen
Einwanderung Regeln übrigens auch in
bestimmte Berufe sei es Fachkräfte sei
es in Pflegeberufe wenn Sie heute in
Pflegeheime gehen in die Kliniken werden
wir ohne gezielte Einwanderung von
Menschen die aus anderen Ländern
gekommen sind hätten wir haben sowieso
schon ein Problem hätten wir ein
massives Problem also haben wir das
angegangen dass in bestimmten Zeiten mit
strengen Voraussetzungen ist möglich ist
einzuwandern aber eben nicht in die
sozial in die in die dass man das Geld
abfischt sondern Arbeitsmarkt in den
Arbeitsmarkt und das brauchen wir in
Deutschland angesichts der Aufgaben so
die vor uns liegen das ist das eine und
jetzt der dritte dass wir natürlich eine
Einwanderung machen müssen unter der
Voraussetzung auch dass wir diejenigen
die illegal in Deutschland sind die sich
hier nicht integrieren die
möglicherweise sogar straffällig gewesen
sind auch umgehend wieder zurückführen
Länder wünschenswert will die Mehrzahl
der Deutschen wissen Sie wie viele
aktuelle ausreisepflichtig sind in
Deutschland nicht aber können sie
schätzen ich will nicht schätzen der ist
eine ganz wichtige Zeit weil es jemand
am Tisch wenn Politiker in der Runde
sagt wir müssen gucken dass wir
schnellere Abschiebungen kriegen dann
gehört zur Realität ist im Moment 300000
Menschen in Deutschland
ausreisepflichtig sind aber eben nicht
abgeschossen
ungefähr 60.000
das hat erstmal einige haben eine
Duldung die können eine Zeit lang
bleiben also auch das ist ist das Leben
ist eben nicht so einfach ja das ist
extrem schwierig aber das gehört eben
zur Realität
wie Joachim stamp als migrationsminister
eben genau das in NRW gemacht hat Leute
zurückzuführen das ist bei manchen
Staaten problematisch weil die Länder
ihre eigene Leute nicht mehr annehmen
aber also Flüchtlinge gezielte
Einwanderung nach Spielregeln und so
schnell wie möglich Leute abschieben und
letzteres hat auch oft ist auch oft eine
rechtliche Frage so dass eben das mag
auf dem Papier nichts miteinander zu tun
haben so wie sie das wie sie gesagt
haben
aber wenn man wenn wir über die
Flüchtlinge sprechen die 2015/2016 zu
uns gekommen sind und wenn man dann
heute sagt okay also jetzt ist der
Zeitraum verstrichen jetzt können
könnten theoretisch all diese Menschen
deutsche werden man beschleunigt ist
sie brauchen fünf Jahre einen recht
Aufenthaltsstatus genau
aber hat das Thema nichts miteinander
auf der anderen Seite die Einbürgerung
wenn ich weiß natürlich schnelleres
Verfahren für den deutschen Pass ja
natürlich hat was miteinander zu tun
denn diese neuen Kriterien fünf Jahre
oder wenn jemand ehrenamtlich tätig ist
sogar noch drei Jahren und wenn Kinder
dann da sind die sind automatisch
deutsche geborene knüpft ihr an und
diejenigen die 15 16 in dieser großen
Zahl gekommen sind es knüpft ihr an wir
im Sommer 2015 und dann die Fluchtwelle
ab dem ersten Wochenende september 2015
und dann jeden Tag allein bei mir und
der Wahlkreis Grenze täglich 1250 war
immer jeder Bus 50 und dann alle halbe
Stunde
die sind jetzt sieben Jahre alt
und nach Nordrhein
was machen Sie liebe Frau Zimmermann
wenn 700 ja nee aber
was heißt denn das was heißt denn das
Nein verliert
selber dabei wenn am Bahnhof von
Salzburg sie kennenzul Salzburg z.B 700
Wahl
sie wissen genau wie die gebirgsäge in
Bad Reichenhall und Bescheid toll
darf ich das bitte
wenn am Bahnhof von Salzburg 700
Flüchtlinge im Pulk aufbrechen über die
Saale 2015 war das so im Oktober die
Sarah Brücke stürmen was wollen da 50
oder 40 Bundes Polizisten
ruft mich der Bürgermeister an und sagt
Peter was soll ich tun ja sage ich
Polizei und ja wir sammeln die eh wieder
ein bisschen ein und so weiter und dann
kommen
beim aktuellen politischen und da finde
ich schon
über die schnelligkeiten deutschen Pass
zu bekommen ich will einfach versuchen
rauszufinden was eigentlich für uns alle
über Voraussetzung sein sollte Deutscher
zu werden was müsste für Sie welche
Bedingungen müssen wir sie erfüllt sein
für die Deutschen liegen auf dem Tisch
die deutsche Sprache muss man
beherrschen man muss sein
Lebensunterhalt selbst bestreiten können
man muss hier wohnen das sind schon drei
Mindestanforderungen die zu erfüllen
sind wie steht es um die Identifikation
erreichbar ist und auch da wieder wir
unterstellen immer dass das größte Glück
für Menschen auf der Erde ist hier zu
leben und die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zu bekommen die
allermeisten die auch von einer Flucht
wieder den Weg zu uns gefunden haben
wollten eigentlich in ihrem Land bleiben
möchte
möglicherweise wir haben sauer völlig zu
Recht sagt seit 2015 die sind jetzt
sieben sechs sieben Jahre alt Kinder
sind hier Träumen Kinder gehen hier zur
Schule sprechen perfekt deutsch die
Eltern haben inzwischen einen
Arbeitsplatz gefunden haben inzwischen
eine Wohnung gefunden und nun jetzt
lassen wir mal alles mit Asyl und
Aufenthaltsrecht Weg nach dieser Zeit zu
sagen es ist für mich als Syrer jetzt
auch dieser Zeit nach diesen sieben
Jahren nachdem meine Kinder ihr geboren
sind auch ein Thema wieder auch ein
Thema deutscher werden zu können mit der
deutschen Staatsangehörigkeit was ist
daran eigentlich so verwerflich ne das
wollte ich von Ihnen wissen wie wir
Integration bekommen und die Frage ist
wie wir die Menschen in den Arbeitsmarkt
bekommen ganz viele das wissen wir alle
Niko Elise haben eben diesen
erfolgreichen Weg nicht gegangen oder
haben ihn nicht gehen können haben eben
keine Arbeit gefunden in all diesen
Jahren wird das durch den deutschen Pass
dass es jetzt die Kernfrage leichter
angeblich geht's ja gar nicht nach Herrn
Müller Arbeit könnte ich nicht deutscher
werden aber ich weiß nicht ob es
wirklich so hart geregelt ist und ich
glaube auch dass die Sprache
Erfordernisse herabgesenkt wurden
zumindest für alte auch für junge das
ist alles nicht mehr so das soll alles
nicht mehr so streng sein diesmal war
vorgestellt und dann empfehle ich Ihnen
mal zu lesen und sie haben sie haben
mich gelesen geführt wann sie die
Rückführungen es ist noch nicht kein
Gesetzentwurf es ist der Vorschlag aus
dem Innenministerium das ist erstmal ein
Vorschlag des Innenministerium ich sagte
ja dass wir in der Ampel uns vorgenommen
haben dieses Thema
Einwanderung zu regeln weil wir Menschen
brauchen die für uns und bei uns
arbeiten das ist ein Fakt und Sie können
in unterschiedlichste Berufe gehen ohne
Einwanderung haben wir ein ernsthaftes
Problem den Wohlstand den wir in
Deutschland haben aufrecht zu erhalten
bleiben in dem Handwerk in den
Fachkräfte genommen nie was auch immer
was kommen viele junge Menschen die eben
auch hier etwas lernen das soll auch
vorkommen so und sich Prozent sind
vielleicht sozialversicherungsverfahren
Punkt wo wir diskutieren dass wir nicht
die Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme
fördern sondern die Einwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt das ist natürlich ganz
entscheidend
und dass wir eben die die hier ich
wiederhole mich hierher gekommen sind
oder versuchen hierher zu kommen um
ausschließlich in die Sozialsysteme zu
kommen dass wir das natürlich nicht
zulassen sprechen wir endlich dann über
Integration Herr Lafontaine wir haben am
vergangenen vor vergangenen Abend
erstaunliche Bilder gesehen ausgerechnet
im Umfeld der Fußballweltmeisterschaft
als ziemlich Belgien gegen Marokko
gespielt hat und als dann in einem Jahr
Einwanderungsland Belgien plötzlich auf
den straßenbus ist genau das passiert
hier dort Menschen die Marokko und die
Daumen gedrückt haben die offenbar ja
seit längerem in Belgien leben die
zerlegen dort in diesem Moment Teile
zumindest der Hauptstadt in Brüssel
Ramsau wie deuten sie diese Bilder was
sehen Sie dort auf diesen Bildern ich
sehe einen wild gewordenen Mob
der sein Gastrecht dort wo sich das
abgespielt hat restlos verspielt hat
warum diese Frage kann ich mir wieder
auch warum passiert das das sind
Menschen die im Belgien leben ja nach
einer eben Verständnis hätten die
Belgien eigentlich die Daumen gedrückt
an dem Abend
ja also da muss ich Ihnen sagen ich habe
auch Freunde die gerade in Argentinien
sind deutsche in Argentinien die darum
gedrückt haben und dann war ja das Spiel
Deutschland gegen Spanien und die eher
für Spanien war weil es also ich würde
den Fußball jetzt mal an der Stelle so
vieles über Identifikation aus einer
sagt was ganz anderes aus es sagt im
Grunde aus dass wir oder muss ich auch
von Deutschland neben Deutschland eben
auch Länder haben dazu gehört auch
Belgien auch die Niederlanden die es
nicht vermocht haben und leider gehören
wir auch dazu unter vielen Regierungen
die es eben nicht vermocht haben die
Integration derer die gekommen sind
nicht nur zu fördern sondern vor allen
Dingen auch zu fordern und die Sprache
zu lernen ist etwas Elementares und eben
auch den Mut zu haben wer bestimmte
kulturelle
akzeptiert dass man das Land ja klar so
und diese falsch verstandene Toleranz
ist in vielen Ländern Europas Frankreich
Belgien in den Niederlanden heller von
den was ihre Erklärung für das was da
auf der Straße passiert ist
dass die Integration nicht gelungen ist
und Integration ist natürlich auch eine
Frage der Zahl die man integrieren will
wenn eben die Zahl sich in Grenzen hält
wenn man eben genügend Mittel hat um die
Menschen zu versorgen und zu integrieren
dann geht das wenn die Zahlen zu groß
werden gibt es Schwierigkeiten und
deshalb will ich nur einen Gedanken mal
Einspielen der noch nicht gefallen ist
im Hinblick auf die Syrer natürlich
haben wir uns damals gefreut wenn auch
qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte kamen aber
wir müssen natürlich sehen das Land ist
ja praktisch völlig zerstört die
Gesellschaft dort kann ja fast nicht
mehr leben und wenn wir noch die paar
Leute abziehen die dort als Ärzte oder
Ingenieur oder was weiß ich gut
ausgebildet sind dann ist das
Neokolonialismus das will ich schon mal
einwerfen und wenn man dann gleichzeitig
noch die Sanktionen aufrecht erhalten
dann ist das nach dem einem Text der UNO
Massenmord weil wenn eben nicht
medizinisches Gerät da ist und nicht
Medizin also Arzneimittel geliefert
werden sterben die Menschen halt langsam
nicht eben durch Bomben aber sie sterben
langsam aber auch bei der
Migrationspolitik müssen wir beide
Seiten sehen also nicht nur unsere
Bedürfnisse sondern auch die Bedürfnisse
der Länder aus denen die Menschen kommen
Integration ist nicht gelungen ganz
viele nicken hier am Tisch bei dem Satz
den Oskar Lafontaine nur noch ganz
kurzer Antwort zum Schluss Herr Knaus
mehr Zeit haben wir nicht was muss
gelingen in Zukunft was ist der
Schlüssel um diese Integration vor allen
Dingen die Identifikation hier in
Deutschland hinzubekommen dass solche
sehen wie dort in Brüssel nicht geht
ganz gut also vor Fußball Hooligans
freue ich mich fürchte ich mich auch ja
deutsche
Österreicher um die Identifikation zu
entscheidende ist das so wie in Kanada
möglichst alle die kommen legal kommen
als Flüchtlinge legal aufgenommen in
Arbeitsmigration mit einer Möglichkeit
vom ersten Tag zu arbeiten dass wir
möglichst wenig lebensgefährliche
populäre Migration haben Deutschland
braucht dringend Migration das Wissen
und sich an die Regeln halten das ist
die faktenaufgabe auch an emotionale
Diskussion überprüft was ist wirklich
danke allen für die und Regeln
Diskussion hier am Tisch Regeln
durchsetzen steht Vorschlag Zimmermann
hat danke Ihnen für die Diskussion danke
an den Müll raus
und auch zu Hause Anhänger von den
nächsten Montag zurück hier bei Bild um
22:15 Uhr
[Musik]